here's what's going on at the movies  screaming into theaters is don't breathe  a blood pumping thriller from the  creators of Evil Dead now you're gonna  see what I see  the master assassin is out to save the  woman he loves in the action packed  sequel mechanic resurrection relentless  aren't they the man changed my life  Robert De Niro steps into the ring for  hands of stone an inspirational boxing  biopic about the legendary trainer ray  ourselves and finally let's find out  what's hot in theaters this weekend with  this week's fan tissa patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket